it's important for writers to understand
that they are not their stories like
this is not
me do you always know where the story is
going when you begin a short story no
not at all um some I really don't know
some I have a stronger sense and then in
some cases I begin stories at the end
which I think a lot of people do um you
know there's something interesting about
that way of you know I mean stories have
to be stories have to have a beginning
middle and end but not necessarily in
that order so starting with the ending
has certain structural opportunities
that are
attractive um but you know in some cases
you know I may have heard a story and so
there's something about that story that
Drew me to it that I may sort of borrow
something of the Arc of that story or I
may take you know elements of that story
or like the first stage of that story I
think I'm I'm never trying to sort of
replicate something that happened in the
world onto the page but certainly you
know things that exist in the world do
find their way onto the page um where a
story ends up I think is is really
important I mean endings like Beginnings
like openings are are really important
but I as has been pointed out
I I I like open-ended endings I I like
giving the characters the open destiny
of life I like giving them a chance to
reveal who they really are I mean in the
case of that story about the jazz
pianist I had been thinking about him
for a very long time and yet I had never
given him the voice to tell his own
story and I
think I think in general I work in first
person and it's mostly because I like to
give characters their own voice and let
their stories go in the direction that
they go in sort of unmanipulated by me
um which involves you know to an extent
following your instincts or your
impulses and in some cases you make
decisions well you
know this character has only loved one
person uh do I
show him with her do I have it just in
his imagination do I dramatize it I mean
there are always lots of choices and
just try to follow the ones that are
like true to the character I don't know
if does that answer the question it does
I'm wondering should a writer know what
their short story is not yes but that
that doesn't happen
until until you're already into the
story I think when you're starting the
story your sense of what it's about is
probably going to change um my friend
Andrew Porter who has a new collection
of stories out the
Disappeared um is very good at this
extremely good at this like he sets up
these Arenas where the dramatic action
takes place and things that belong in
that Arena that are in some way
contributing to the story that's being
told in that Arena are allowed to make
their way in into the action and if if
they don't fit or if it seems like it's
just too much like you know stories
can't be about everything not only that
they can't be about to too many things
they have to ultimately make some
choices about what they're about and
then hopefully the specificity of those
choices will lead to universality but
you know there's no guarantee that that
will happen do you believe that great
stories never leave the body once
they've entered it that's a great
question um Lawns which I read you the
opening paragraph from has never left my
body I I I went to a reading when I was
19 years old I had no idea who Mona
Simpson was I had no idea what that
story was I I really was just learning
about literature in many ways for the
first time I mean I knew some things but
I didn't know very much and she gave
this reading and she read that story out
loud and I'm not I'm not exaggerating my
my face was covered in tears at the end
of that reading it was like I I didn't
even know I even had those feelings that
were summoned up by that story and
I I had such a visceral reaction and
such a
um it was it was character it was place
it was subject matter it was you know
how do you love someone
who treats you a certain way like human
beings are amazing we have so much love
in us
that we we we even yeah it's it's it's
it's very it's a very complicated
story but it doesn't use characteres it
doesn't use two-dimensional characters
it deals with ve very difficult material
and three-dimensional characters people
who really hurt each other really love
each other and it's the same how do you
know you have a complete story
yeah that's a very hard one um I think
really the only answer to that is to
look at an actual story um because
stories that Apprentice writers write
are often not complete but they don't
understand and it might be because it
needs more scenes it might be because it
needs fewer scenes it might be that
there's an extraneous character that has
to be written out of the story it may be
that there's a character that needs to
be added to the story I mean there's so
many ways to answer that and it's a very
important question I
mean and I think ultimately if you write
enough stories and you study you know
Masters like Flander o Conor and you
read what she has to say about writing
stories and Carver and and so
on you'll
eventually
learn how to complete your own stories
but even so you're going to want to show
them to other people and make sure that
they feel complete to other people too
when I say other people I mean other
people
who understand what a complete story is
now the story that you told me about uh
that's one of her famous ones where she
seduces a man in a barn who supposedly
has this heart condition right was that
based on anything that had happened to
her I don't know and um I mean I I don't
really delve into that area you know
when I
um when I teach um it's a ground rule of
my classes that we don't speculate at
all on the writers
real life connection to the potential
material um so for example let's say
that one of my students puts up a story
about a character who's lived on the
streets for five years it is not
acceptable to ask whether the writer has
lived on the streets for five years
because what we're trying to do in a
fiction writing Workshop is
like understand story
understand what makes them work like
what could make them work better um what
could make them complete um and so what
I asked the students to do is say okay
here's the
story here's the reader and here's the
writer reader you try to address the
story and writer you're going to listen
on behalf of the story so the so the
reader and the writer are not actually
having a direct conversation in my
classes because it's important for
writers to understand that they are not
their stories like this is not me I may
have written
this this is a work of art that I
created and I need to learn how to make
this the best work of art I can
independent of whatever my personal
experience has been and the reader is
tasked with helping me to to you know
give her honest
sensitive response to the work so that
the writer can say okay you know six
people in the class didn't understand
something so maybe it wasn't that
clear this is also a way of
depersonalizing the workshop experience
um I've been in workshops where things
got nasty
because um you know personal things were
brought into the conversation I really
think that like when you're talking
about fiction writing you should talk
about fiction writing otherwise I don't
know there's all sorts of dangers that
can come of that that's a great rule
because I think you can be so much Freer
if you don't feel that there's going to
be judgment and there's going to be
judgment doesn't matter if it's squeaky
clean or something so salacious that it
wouldn't be safe for work I think people
are fear that their their families their
culture their their peers will judge
them they'll judge themselves it's true
I mean it's very delicate um that
balance in class I
mean I I really think I you know I've
seen like people brought to tears in
workshops like it's it has the potential
to really hurt people because people
often you know put something of their
soul into their writing I I understand
that like I it's because I understand
that that I structure my classes the way
that I do like I really I don't want the
the writer to ever feel that the reader
is personally criticizing him or her
because to me that's when a a a a
workshop can start to break down and
also
it's it is really important for a writer
to
learn that he or she is separate from
the text that he or she has produced
because how is the writer ever going to
be able to revise anything if like she
thinks that everything she wrote is like
chiseled and
marble you you have to look at your work
as something that's in development
that's at a certain draft stage you know
some stories
can be written in a few drafts some may
need 20 or 30 drafts it's the writer's
job to figure out what the text needs
not what the writer needs not what the
writer personally needs but what the
text needs and that's exactly what I
want the reader to be addressing
and when it works well the workshop can
be a magical place I mean I've seen oh
I'm that one woman's story it was in
American short fiction I don't know how
many thousands of uh submissions they
get a year but it's a lot it's very hard
to get in there so I mean it's yeah when
it works it's it's it can be really cool
I love that so no no cross talk or no
you're not uh no one asks questions
about is this you never right I like
that totally off limit yeah um yeah um
yeah so people are allowed to critique
but it's not uh it's done in a way about
the story exactly
okay